hey thanks for coming to the YouTube
channel every single week on a Sunday I
always like to do a Q&A where i read
through people's questions and answer
them best I can
I'm putting out a new video every single
day so please do smash the like button
subscribe to the channel if you're not
already so last week's questions we had
some great questions beaky bk1 said
another great video Sanyal how do you
convince landlords and agents when you
have a zero track record great question
I think if you've got a zero track
record and you want to convince a
landlord or an agent to do business with
you what you need to think is rather
than thinking you're thinking of the
thing that you haven't got going for you
you're thinking I haven't done this
before and that's what you're focusing
on you're focusing on the fact that
you've never done this before
what you want to do before you do any
business deal with anyone is you want to
list all the things that you have got
going for you so if you're if you're
going up to a landlord or an agent
you're gonna be thinking okay what have
I got going for me well I'm offering the
landlord a great service I have got my
money and affairs in order with good
credit I know I don't
I've got a good track record but I know
the area wow I've got I've done some
really good training I've got just list
all the things that you've got going for
you we're all doubt different cards in
life it's just about dealing the cards
you're dealt with flipping flipping it
around so I would probably say BK one
change your mindset rather than thinking
you've got a zero track record think of
all the things that you have got going
for you there's no reason why you can't
do a deal with a zero track record
everyone has to start somewhere so just
go kick some ass all right we've got
Matthew Whiteside he says hi Samuel
what's the best way to calculate a
property's true value what resources do
you use to do this many different
resources many different ways there's
basically three things that we do number
one is if I'm trying to find a value of
a house I'm gonna see what else is
selling in the area that's similar
sometimes people say you know I've got
this house it's on for a hundred but the
owner has accepted 90 that's ten
thousand pound off of the asking price
the truth is it doesn't really matter
what the asking price is on that house
it matters what the
true current market values and the
stereo studio the first ways what else
is selling and what are they asking for
if they're all asking for 19 this person
is asking for a hundred it's probably
it's probably on an inflated price
secondly is to look at what they've sold
for so - you can go on Rightmove and
look on the house prices section and you
can see exactly what's sold in the
street so do some comparables and what's
sold like for like and then the third
way is you can ask you can ask a valuer
to give you a value or a mortgage lender
and you can absolutely get get an
accurate value that way
there are software's and sites and stuff
you can use real time valuation home
track that's it that's a really good one
Maus price comm that's a good one so I
think it's just about you know seen
what's selling seeing what's sold
speaking to experts and doing like like
for like comparison comparables and it
should give you a pretty good idea on
what a house is worth but ultimately a
house is only worth what someone's
prepared to pay for it next hue-hue one
says mr leads what's easier to make a
passive income on property versus
business okay so you can make passive
income on business if you if you set up
a business and then you replace yourself
and you employ someone to manage the
business absolutely you can create
passive income or business however the
thing about property I would say
property hands down
when you're buying a property you know
the management companies you don't need
to employ them you need to employ a
full-time manager to buy a house or to
build a portfolio they get paid on
results everybody within your property
business you know whereas if you're
running an actual business then you need
to employ people if you're buying
properties you buy a house you pay a
solicitor to complete on the legal side
of things you don't pay the solicitor
unless he does the job you pay him on
results then once you've done that and
you've paid your mortgage broker and
your solicitor you pay a management
company it's also clock for property I
think is the number one definitely the
number one way to get passive income and
that's why I love property so much I got
some friends they're millionaires
they're doing really well but they're
constantly you know dealing with staff
and problems I've got staff I have
problems
but property yeah I think I think it
wins it wins all right
next which city is better for rent
income Manchester or Birmingham that's
from Marius which rents are probably
higher in Birmingham but it doesn't
matter about where rents are higher it
matters where you're going to get a
better return on investment in London
the rents are really high but the houses
are also really high so it's all about
the return on investment which where
would you get that return on investment
probably similar
I mean maybe Manchester I similar it
also depends the so many factors you
can't just say what's better Manchester
or Birmingham I'd the person who asked
me that question so Marius I would say
which city do you have better contacts
with which city do you know that ins and
outs of the good streets and the bad
streets you know it's you can make any
city work as long as you know the city
as long as you've got good connections
personally I don't have properties in
Manchester but I have many in Birmingham
but that's because I know Burma better
so don't look at the rent
always look at the return on investment
all right last one this is cartoon box
he says is there a formula way to
calculate a good rent to rent or rent to
serviced accommodation deal yes there is
so a couple things firstly is if I'm
doing a rent to rent deal I want to make
a 100 percent return on investment in
the first year and that's like as a
minimum so if I'm going to put down say
five thousand pounds on the furniture
and rent to the landlord and bits and
bobs like that within the first twelve
months I need to have made at least five
thousand pounds back in profit so after
year one I'm up the second thing is as
well which is to kind of a rule of thumb
is I say with a rent to rent you you
really want to be going for a minimum of
five hundred pound
cash flow so passive not passive 500
pounds cash flow profit because I say
not passively because you're gonna have
to do it with a rental rent you're
normally gonna have to manage it and do
stuff and be a little bit involved not
necessarily but you're all five in Japan
a month because you don't own it if
you're buying houses and you own them
you're getting paid twice you're getting
paid to the capital appreciation you
also get painful
if you don't rent to rent you don't own
it so you're only getting paid from the
rent which means that you want the rent
to be at least 500 pounds a month and
then if it's not if there's a problem if
there's some bad tenants move out and
the boiler breaks are some issues at
least you know you're not gonna be going
into the minuses so following the plan a
month profit in your back pocket per
rent to rent is really kind of like the
minimum what you should be aiming for
anyway folks I hope you enjoyed that I
hope you found that useful if you've got
questions about property or offshoot
questions niggling property questions
please do ask me anything
comment your question below I'll go
through them and I'll try my best to
answer as many as I can next week really
appreciate your support please don't
forget to subscribe stay tuned and I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]